today on the matt walsh show a facebook
documentary series
shows the trials and tribulations of a
father who identifies as a mother and is
now
trying to breastfeed his child
shockingly it's not going well also five
headlines including joe biden claiming
that voter id laws are the new jim crow
and anthony fauci says that your
three-year-old still
needs to be masked i mean my
three-year-old has never been masked to
begin with but
he's saying you still need to have a
mask on the three-year-old and another
espn host another one finds himself in a
racism controversy and in our daily
cancellation
we'll talk about the campaign for
greater fat acceptance
in the workplace all of that and more
today on the matt welsh show
i want to tell you about helix mattress
you know helix mattress i think i had
has proven for me to be kind of a
blessing and a curse a curse only in the
sense that it's so comfortable
that i i rely on it and when i'm out
traveling at a hotel or something like
that
staying at somebody's house and they
don't have a helix mattress i struggle
you know i've become kind of a coddled
baby in that way because helix
mattresses are just so
comfortable and the reason they're so
comfortable is that they you can get
them customized to match
exactly your body type and all of your
sleep preferences and you get the
perfect mattress for you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or your back however you sleep
whatever your body type is there's a
specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique taste
you don't need to take their word for it
either or my word for helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress of
2019 and 2020 by
gq and wired magazine if you want to see
why that is if you want to experience it
for yourself just go to helixsleep.com
walls take their two minute sleep quiz
and they will match you with the perfect
mattress for you
and then all you got to do is buy that
mattress and right now as far as buying
mattresses helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders for our listeners at helix
sleep.com
walsh that again is helix sleep.com
walsh for up to 200
off your mattress order now before we
get going today i need to mention
something it's pretty exciting or at
least mildly interesting i don't want to
oversell it i did just start my own
weekly newsletter everyone else has
newsletters
these days there's a lot of newsletters
out there
but those newsletters are written by
other people
this is the world's first newsletter to
be written by me
so once again i am an innovator and a
trendsetter so if you want to be blessed
by this newsletter
once a week all you have to do is go to
mattwalchreport.com
i have my own fancy url and everything
mattwalchreport.com give us your email
address and
you'll get that newsletter every friday
okay now here's something that may or
may not appear in this week's newsletter
i may not be able to stomach talking
about it anymore beyond this segment
but a video went viral this week
featuring a clip from a show called
nine months with courtney cox now as the
title suggests the show is
supposed to document the journey of
various parents through pregnancy birth
and into the early days and months
of raising a newborn one of the couples
profiled in the show
are a man and a woman named ahanu
and patrona ahanu is the mom
and patrona is the dad this is kind of
hard to keep track of because you know
since this is facebook we're talking
about and this is also modern society
we're talking about
there's a catch ahanu the mom identifies
as the dad and patrona the dad
identifies as the mom an article on the
federalists gives more background it
says quote
ahanu a female identifying as a male and
her partner patrona
a male identifying as a female were
caught off guard by the pregnancy news
because they both were using hormone
replacement therapy
as the episodes go on cox claims the
couple faces discrimination at the
doctor's office because someone wrongly
assumed each partner
sex they didn't even speak to me ahanu
said
quote i just felt like they just made
assumptions making an assumption from
the very beginning without even asking
our names not asking a thing about us
patrona added
well just to make a side note here um
that's because
when it comes to your biological sex now
really we don't need to say biological
sex because there's no other kind
um but when it comes to your to your sex
uh your name doesn't matter
we don't need anything we need to know
anything about your personality we don't
need to know what your hobbies are
what your interests what your hopes and
dreams are
because it's it's all that matters is
the biology
they determine that physically
which is why you could dig up the
remains of someone
long ago dead and tell what sex they
were
you can't interview them you can't ask
their name you can't ask how they
identify
and yet you can tell the sex oftentimes
um back to the federalists it says
leading up to the home birth the couple
opted to prevent
further which they opted to prevent
further medical discrimination and
trauma the show also documented the
couple's struggle to claim
my truth quote unquote and choose who in
their families will respect their wishes
to raise a non-binary child
a hunter said quote the gender binary
was very violent and growing up i had a
gender assigned to me and it caused me a
lot of unnecessary trauma
it's very lonely and isolating like i
know my parents could do more
patrona also expressed reluctance that
his family would choose to ignore the
baby sex because their minds are filled
with christian supremacy
now this is all deranged enough as it is
but it gets worse
here is the actual viral clip mentioned
earlier it shows patrona the biological
father attempting to breastfeed the
newborn
you probably didn't think you'd get a
chance to see male breastfeeding on the
show today
and you certainly don't want to see it
i'm sure but here it is anyway let's
watch
i just felt really thankful for hanu
for creating our family
oh i have to put it over here
the baby has been able to latch but
i've not been able to produce any milk
it's okay because
we're going to supplement the feeding
with formula so that
my baby is still getting the the
nutrients that they need
but i'm still feeling hopeful i
appreciate you so much for all your work
and i appreciate you also dating i'm
gonna die without you
[Music]
is he getting any milk the person behind
the camera asks well no
he isn't because he's being breastfed by
his dad
and dads don't produce milk now it'll be
pointed out by some people attempting to
justify this grotesque display
that actually technically in some cases
men
can lactate and that's true there's
always people ready with the
with the with the rare medical exception
saying well here's this
crazy exception i've i found on google
which which totally undermines the
entire
uh sexual binary
there have been a few recorded instances
of this due to medical anomalies of
or other circumstances i think i think a
certain kind of tumor can have this
effect
for example but these are
medical anomalies rare cases extreme
exceptions and there's no reliable
recorded instance of a man actually
producing enough milk to keep a baby fed
there are however billions of recorded
instances of women producing enough milk
for a baby because that
is how nature has designed it but as
we've seen
nature is often told to take a back seat
it is often subverted in order to serve
the emotional needs
of deluded narcissists speaking of
narcissism this is an aspect of our
contemporary
gender madness and really our
contemporary madness
as a whole it's an aspect that isn't uh
talked about a lot
there's a lot of mental illness at work
here clearly
but there's also something simpler and
more common which is narcissism
the conviction that myself
is the center of all things and all of
reality must conform to my
expectations for it there's perhaps no
picture that
captures narcissism more profoundly
or grossly than that of a father calling
himself a mother while trying to
breastfeed his helpless infant
and what about that infant you know
we're told that the lifestyle choices
other people make are not our business
because nobody's being harmed
this isn't hurting anyone but out they
say
but you know the baby counts as someone
the baby is a person and he he didn't
choose to be caught in the middle of
this he didn't choose to become a prop
in this
macabre stage play
he didn't choose to be part of uh the
costume that is being worn here
and that's the case for many kids born
into these sorts of situations
or all of the kids born in these
situations none of them chose it
and really it's the case for all kids
actually
across across all of western culture
even those with moms and dads who are
actually moms and dads and call
themselves as such
we have a whole generation of people
born into a reality that has been
completely redefined
to suit what was once a tiny minority
all humans in history until now were
born into a world where at least the
most basic realities were acknowledged
and recognized
we now have at least one generation in
the west
and more to follow who will be deprived
of that blessing and it's a sad thing
that we can call it a blessing
that we could call reality to simply
live in reality
to be raised in reality
and to be taught about the most basic
aspects of reality the fact that we have
to even call that a blessing now
tells you everything you need to know
but we have
general we're gonna have generations of
kids millions of kids
who are born without that not given that
so is is this affecting someone
is this harming other people yeah i'd
say so
now let's get to our five headlines
well we got to talk about joe biden to
begin with but i i did see this
i wanted to mention sad story
very sad story uh apparently
and this is in um this is from wtvg
13 abc local affiliate
serving ohio and uh southeast michigan
anyway
there was a they had a big george floyd
mural
that um collapsed
you know we've seen all these george
floyd murals all over the country
people painting these murals to honor uh
a convicted violent felon who
forced his way into a woman's home at
gunpoint and robbed her
um and then died while high on fentanyl
and resisting arrest
people making murals to honor him and
and one of them
it was you know on a brick wall and it
kind of collapsed and at first the
pictures were
circulating yesterday and people were
saying how does this happen at this
what a tragedy uh that this mural fell
apart
was this some good samaritan i mean not
good samaritan was this some
dastardly evildoer who destroyed the
mural well it turns out
now here's the update this is according
to the abc affiliate
witnesses have said that the mural was
struck
by lightning and then collapsed
and that's that is that is something
isn't it
you know it's not it's not often that
you see
damage to you know the the brick siding
on a on a
on a building because of of lightning i
mean i'm not saying it never happens but
it's pretty rare
how many murals have we seen that have
been destroyed that have been struck
by lightning from the sky
that's the report anyway it was struck
by lightning
oh man how sad how unfortunate i mean
it's almost
it's almost as if this is some kind of
sign
i don't know i don't want to make too
much out of it
but uh it it it's it's it's almost like
you you might
think that maybe it's almost like god is
saying to us
hey you know you shouldn't be
celebrating
a violent felon and horrible person
who forced his way into a woman's home
and robbed her at gunpoint and then died
while
overdosing on fentanyl it's almost like
god is saying that to us
you know the left they have their
statues and murals and monuments that
they want to destroy and so they have to
go themselves and do it
mobs of people go and do it
but this one this was taken care of from
from the heavens
i don't know very interesting
lots of conclusions could be drawn all
right let's move here number one joe
biden gave his a big speech on voter
rights
and we played the clip yesterday of jen
pasaki talking about what you know
previewing
what this speech would contain the
actual thing itself
was somehow even more deranged and
dishonest
than than it was originally than other
than how it was originally sold let's
let's listen
17 states have enacted not just proposed
but enacted
28 new laws to make it harder for
americans to vote
not to mention and gets this nearly 400
additional bills
republican members of the state
legislatures are trying to pass
the 21st century jim crow assault is
real
it's unrelenting and we're going to
challenge it vigorously
the assault on free and fair elections
is just such a threat
literally i've said it before
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
the confederates back then never
breached the capitol
as insurrectionists did on january the
6th
i'm not saying this alarm you i am
saying this because you
should be alarmed uh i'm not saying this
to alarm you but you should be alarmed
look i'm not trying to alarm you but be
very alarmed
uh he says it's not hyperbole but of
course it is hyperbole this is the
greatest threat
in fact he seems to be saying it's not
just the greatest threat
since the civil war but it's a greater
threat
than the civil war this is worse than
the civil war he seems to actually be
saying
whether he's saying it's worse than or
as bad as
uh either way it's just as dishonest and
and obscene
we're talking about laws here's what
we have to keep repeating it and
sometimes i don't
i feel like i repeat myself too much
but the lies are repeated every single
day ad nauseam and this is the tactic to
repeat them and repeat them and repeat
them
until the people who know the truth get
tired of pointing it out
and it's kind of
you you win that way but the other side
just gives up
kind of flooding the zone with all these
lies and so you have to keep repeating
the truth
and the truth here is that we're talking
about laws that would simply require
people to produce some kind of
identification in order to vote
just like they have to produce
identification to do almost anything
else in adult life
if you want to be a functioning adult in
modern society
you already need to have some kind of
photo id
and so all we're saying is let's take
that and let's apply it to voting
if you don't have a photo id great news
you've got four years to get one
can you manage it in four years i think
you can
i don't care what position you're in i
don't care if we're talking about
uh in elderly you know let's take the
most extreme case
elderly poverty stricken
blind woman living out you know
100 miles from the nearest town
if this if if hypothetical if this
person even exists
doesn't have an id somehow can we get
that hypothetical person in id in the
next uh in the next three or four years
i think we can even the most extreme
hypothetical cases
but speaking of speaking of people
living out in the country
because we're kind of we're it's they're
playing both sides here
we're getting we're getting both
versions of the of the story
what joe biden is saying and what we
hear from democrats usually is that
voter id laws
are racist it's just like jim crow it's
a conspiracy to keep black people out of
the voting booth
which is to imply that black people
don't know how to get ids
that's the implication black people are
too incompetent to figure out how to get
an id
which is total nonsense obviously
but then you've got camila harris we
played the club a couple days ago
where she's talking about in in in a way
that's just as patronizing and insulting
she's talking about rural americans and
how they don't they can't even
they got no kinkos around which is true
because kinko's don't exist but they
can't figure out how to make photocopies
they live way out there in the country
so so which is it
is this something that's targeting rural
americans
or is it targeting um black people is it
jim crow
now of course there are black people
living out in rural america but that's
predominantly whites
and so if you're telling that telling us
that these are laws
uniquely affecting rural people
that you're talking about predominantly
white people
so even if the laws are wrong
if they're if they're victimizing rural
people
and people who live in the cities then
it's not racist at least
it's just wrong across the board if the
laws are not wrong
but they can't be racist in that case
i think what they're the reason why
they're the balancing act they're trying
to
trying to accomplish here is that
yeah they want to be able to call the
laws racist that's the hook that's the
selling point
for them is that it's racist
but at the same time it's it's hard they
can't really explain why
let's say a black person living in a
city
can't get an id you got dmvs all over
the place
i mean i i know here in nashville living
in the city uh
we've got every every five miles there's
a dmv
so it's hard to explain why can't you
get an id
and then so then they have to go to to
explain why you know a circumstance
where a person might not be able to
get an id they have to go to people
living in far flung
far-fetched areas rural america
separated from
from modern civilization
and of course again if you're going if
you're if that's who you're talking
about then you're talking about
predominantly white people
so that's the the way they switch things
up and hope you won't notice
they say oh these these laws are racist
they're uh
they're gonna prevent black people from
voting and then you ask well what do you
mean why why would they stop anyone from
voting what are you talking about
and they say well what about rural
people living out in the country
but yeah but you were just that's not
what you just said that's not that's not
the
situation you were just talking about
so it's all it's all just dishonest
obviously
going down to number two tony fauci is
still at it clinging on to his relevance
desperately and just like he wants your
three-year-old to cling to his mask and
here he is
he's asked about uh what about what
about little kids kids over two
we had been told all last year they're
supposed to be wearing a mask
do they still have to wear a mask and
fauci says yes
what is this spread of the delta variant
mean for them for the children under
the age of 12 and what's the timeline
for when they might become eligible
the children who are not able to get
vaccinated because of their
age should follow their parents should
follow with them
the guidelines of the cdc that
unvaccinated children
of a certain age greater than two years
old should be wearing masks
no doubt about that that's the way to
protect them from getting infected
because if they do
they can then spread the infection to
someone else
so the cdc guidelines for unvaccinated
people including children
are not changed at all we are currently
doing
we being the federal government together
in collaboration
with the pharmaceutical companies age
de-escalation
studies namely looking at the safety
and the immunogenicity of vaccines in
children from 12 to 9 years old then
from nine to six
then from six to two years old and then
ultimately
from six months to two years old those
data
will likely be available by the end of
the year
and then it will be up to the fda to
decide
when they would make a recommendation
that
in fact this could be done in the sense
of vaccinating children
of that age
this guy's really he is really a scumbag
this is this is a villainous person
he truly is
this is an old man been in the
government
leeching off of the government a
parasite
for decades now
bungling everything every step of the
way never accomplishing anything of note
in his entire worthless career
and now he refuses to go away he could
just go go go away you had your time in
the sun
right off into the sunset we don't need
you now we didn't need you then
we certainly don't need you now go home
and be retired
you're what 75 or something
just go home but he can't do it he's
addicted
doing the cable news hits
people treating him like an authority
figure carrying what he has to say he's
addicted to it he cannot leave it
what did he just say he said not only
should your three-year-old still be
wearing a mask and i say
still but there should be no still
because your three-year-old never should
have worn a mask to begin with
but um not only should three-year-olds
still be wearing a mask he says but
and for the foreseeable future
he says well we gotta uh the end of the
year we'll have these studies back and
then the fda will make a recommendation
and the cdc will say something and then
we'll figure it out and then we'll do
this and that and
you know maybe by the maybe by the time
they they're
you know hit their 18th birthday they
can take the mask off maybe
in some ways i want to say it doesn't
matter what fauci says there's no point
in even getting upset about it because
who is still listening to this fraud
this goon who's still listening to him
if you're still listening dan i know
there are people who are um that's why
he's on
msnbc to begin with the kinds of people
that would watch msnbc and take it
seriously are the kinds of people that
listen to uh
listen to fouchy which is why he's there
but
we're certainly at the point now where
if you are being influenced by this to
put a mask
on your young child uh then you're the
problem i can't even blame fauci anymore
you are the problem
this is abusive what you're doing to
your child
there's no excuse anymore because you
can't say
well we're right in the middle of this
pandemic and
you know the virus is raging and you
you're just
you're taking every precaution that you
can you don't know exactly what's
happening you're afraid you're afraid
for your kid
that's the excuses people offered six
months ago a year ago
oh a year ago let's say um
that doesn't fly anymore
so if you're still putting a mask on
your child then you're the problem
fortunately i can say i haven't even
seen this i guess this is there's a very
regional thing now
it'll probably stay that way um
i could say here in tennessee i haven't
seen anyone i think maybe i've seen
i don't know a handful of people over
the last few weeks
wearing masks and they were all adults
i would like to think that this is not a
problem anywhere but i know i think i
know better than that
okay speaking of children page six
reports
on this it says a british charity
committed to limiting family size to
help save the environment
this week gave prince harry and meghan
markle an award for their decision to
have just two children
population matters will award the couple
who welcomed their second child last
month
the equivalent of 695 dollars for their
enlightened decision
to have a small family and for serving
as role models for others
695 dollars well these are that's going
to come in handy because we know that um
harry and megan they're on they've hit
financially hard times that's why they
were complaining about it to oprah
cut off from their family having to make
do
in their 15 bedroom mansion with only
their netflix deal
and their book deals and all the
interviews they're getting paid for
so that's 700 bucks that'll come in
handy
um the the statement from the charity
says having a smaller family reduces our
impact on the earth and provides a
better chance for all of our children
for their children and future
generations to flourish on a healthy
planet
we can we commend the duke and duchess
for taking this enlightened decision
and for affirming that a smaller family
is also a happy family
uh yeah well you know bigger families
aren't happy at all like i came from uh
i have five brothers and sisters nothing
but despair
and misery in large families
in reality it's it's it seems to me to
be the opposite i mean we're all going
to be biased by our own personal
experiences but
i'm not saying the people that came from
come from smaller families aren't happy
but
i come from a larger family um
i know a lot of larger families i've
been in that circle
go to a homeschool convention sometime
lots of very big families
and people are very very happy it's one
of the first things you notice
but uh they're saying that the way to
save future generations that's how sick
and twisted this is the way to save
future generations is to eliminate them
is to ensure that there are no more
future generations
because having two kids that's the award
here we'll be rewarding them for having
two children
two children is below replacement level
and what's considered quote-unquote
replacement level can
vary depending on the country what part
of the world you're in because you
factor in the mortality rate and all
those kinds of things
but um even in the united states what is
considered replacement level
is more than two
so this is below replacement level
if everyone across the world if they if
they limited themselves only to that
to two or fewer then eventually we would
see
the extinction of the human race
which really these kinds of
environmental groups
population matters and so on that's
really what they want
they want to save the environment by
extinguishing human life they see human
life as a
as a bad thing they see us as a cancer
a plague on the earth
and so they've tallied it tallied it up
and uh
and they've said well this is this is
how many people we should have
and anything more than that that's
overpopulation we've got the population
and the overpopulation of course the
funny thing is
people talk about overpopulation they
never seem to count themselves in the
over category
which is why all the people worried
about overpopulation you never see a
you know a rash of of mass suicides
among those people
because they're not going to take
themselves out of the equation no they
want you to take your children out of
the equation
and your lineage your bloodline
future descendants that's what they want
to take out of the equation
save the environment by extinguishing
human life that's basically the idea
which raises a question what is the
point of an environment
without conscious rational beings around
to
experience it so we want to save
this planet for the trees and and
non-rational beings
by taking the rational beings out of the
equation
we are the ones who have placed value
on all of this stuff in the first place
and that's especially the case if uh
if you don't believe in god which almost
everyone who worries about
overpopulation
none of them are believers
and so for them there's no objective
value to
the earth there's no objective value to
a tree
it's all subjective we have
we have decided we have placed the value
on these things
so you take us out as rational beings
capable of projecting value take us out
and then what value does the tree have
this is an even bigger problem for
people who don't believe in god
and they're all the ones it's almost
entirely people worried about
overpopulation are
don't believe in god speaking of which i
wanted to actually make this point we
were talking about voting rights earlier
um and i you know as i as i
always say i i don't hide the fact that
um
i don't i don't believe that that voting
rights are this
sacred god-given inherent right
universal to all mankind i think it's a
it's more of a privilege that you should
qualify
you should be granted after you qualify
for it that's what i think voting rights
should be um
and a lot of people don't like that i
get criticized every time i bring that
up
and i was getting attacked online for
that yesterday
but once again you run into the same
kind of problem
now there are lots of people who who
disagree about disagree with me about
voting rights who
believe in god but certainly on the left
almost everyone on the left it will
disagree with my assertion
that voting rights are not inherent and
god-given
yet they run into the same kind of
problem because many of them don't
believe in god
so how can they disagree with me they
don't think that any rights
are god-given which means
by extension by definition voting rights
aren't god-given
god-given or inherent because those are
basically the same that's the same idea
if there's no god then you can't have
any god-given rights
obviously and if there's no god you also
can't have any inherent human right
those are synonyms they mean the same
thing what exactly is an inherent human
right
without god what does that mean
how can we have rights entitlements
like we're entitled to things the
universe owes us
just by the nature of the fact that we
exist
how can we have that without god
what does it mean to say we have
inherent value
our inherent rights come from our
inherent value as human beings well we
don't have that
there is no objective value without god
this is a real problem that uh you you
rarely hear anyone on the left really
grapple with you don't believe in god
what even do you mean when you talk
about human rights
it would seem like without god rights
would have to be
entirely subjective something granted by
the government
and if the government can grant it then
the government can take it away and you
can't really complain when they do
because they're the ones who decide
rarely do i hear that problem tackled by
anyone on the left
all right let's move on now i i have to
tell you first of all before we play
this clip that
i don't know anything about baseball
because i generally prefer sports that i
can remain awake while watching
that's i like to be awake while i'm
watching sports i don't like for my
sports to double as sedatives
and that's just me so i'm no i'm no
expert on the sport as i dive into this
and in fact i don't even know who the
guy
is that we're talking about here that's
how out of the loop i am when it comes
to baseball but
shohei otani is the biggest superstar in
baseball apparently
news to me and he's from japan um
stephen a smith
inexplicably one of the biggest stars on
espn
he had some thoughts about that and then
he had an apology to offer for those
thoughts but let's let's play the
thoughts first here he is
when i look at ohtani he is big time
beirut 33 home runs baton 279
got a four on one record with a 379 era
as a pitcher
this brother is special make no mistake
about it
but the fact that you got a foreign
player that doesn't speak english
that needs an interpreter believe it or
not i think contributes
to harming the game to some degree when
that's your box office appeal
it needs to be somebody like bryce
harper mike trout
those guys and unfortunately at this
moment in time
that's not the case now obviously sammy
sosa we learned later during his
testimony on capitol hill
that suddenly he needed an interpreter
you know baseball being betty very good
to him
you know what i'm saying that wasn't
enough he needed an interpreter to speak
for him when he was on capitol hill
certainly didn't need that when he was
smacking those home runs i'm not taking
anything away from ohtani
i know what he's doing on the field i
know it's nothing short of spectacular
and i understand that baseball is an
international sport
itself in terms of participation but
when you talk about an
audience gravitating to the tube or to
the ballpark
to actually watch you okay
i don't think it helps that the number
one face
is a dude that needs an interpreter so
you can understand what the hell
uh shockingly stephen a smith
shortly after saying that did did issue
an apology
uh he said in part i'm sincerely sorry
let me apologize as i'm watching things
unfold let me say
but i never intended to offend any
community particularly the asian
community and especially
shohei otani himself as an
african-american keenly aware of the
damage stereotyping has done to many in
this country
it should have elevated my sensitivities
even more based on my words i failed in
that regard and it's on me
and me alone i'm so so sorry please
forgive me please don't take my job away
etc and so forth now here's what i'll
say about this
and i hate espn i think steven a smith
is obnoxious i have no desire to try to
bail him out or defend him
but in observation
um smith was asked whether it's good for
baseball that ohtani is the number one
attraction that was the question if he's
only allowed to give
one answer to the question then don't
ask it
his point is that the best thing for
baseball is what he was saying
in his opinion which he's now claiming
was not his opinion
but the opinion that he was clearly
expressing is that the best thing for
baseball
is if the biggest stars are homegrown
heroes you know hometown boys
um that's the best thing he's saying or
was saying before he were treated
that's that's not a it's not a racist
point
it's not xenophobic it's a point about
marketing
in sports agree or disagree
that's what it is
um but here's the real mystery to me
see if you're gonna say this knowing
where we are in our culture
and knowing that you're on espn of all
things the woke scold central
then you must know you must know
that there's going to be a huge backlash
you would have to know that
how do you not know that
i'm not i'm not even saying that you you
shouldn't make the point
that's your opinion you were asked the
question it's a question about marketing
and baseball and and so you have your
point you made it great
what i don't get is how can you be so
stupid
that as to not know what the response is
going to be
if you say it and you know what the
response is going to be and you're
prepared for it
and so you stand up to it and say hey
that's my opinion
i gave it and if you don't like it i
don't care i'm not hurting anybody it's
just my opinion
if you had taken that approach i'd
respect it
but instead he apologizes immediately
which which tells me
that he didn't realize there would be a
backlash
to that opinion that he just expressed
how can you be so oblivious as to not
know that
that's the only thing i find surprising
about this
all right let's move now to reading the
youtube comments
this uh is from joe he says there's
plenty of bipac representation in the
geosciences kanye informed us all about
the practice of gold digging
well done sir well done pop culture
tie-in
not very not a very current tie-in but
you know even so
keon says the only reason the daily wire
wouldn't make the sweet baby gang shirt
is because shapiro is just
jealous he's not as popular as you matt
yeah that's right
and he's jealous that i that he can't do
as many pull-ups as i can do so
that's all that's all this is adam says
uh by the way don't check the podcast
charts to confirm who's more popular
here
just take my word for it adam says the
problem with those statues is that in a
culture where most people spend their
lives whining on twitter
it's a reminder of people actually doing
something with their lives
yeah i do think that's part of it i
think that there is some envy there's
some jealousy going on
um motivating
the the destruction of statues
uh that's not what motivated the
destruction of the george ford
floyd mural those are motivations
wait those were cosmic motivations i
can't speak to those
but as far as the mobs of people tearing
down statues i think that is part of it
these are losers who have never achieved
anything in their lives
um have never even sniffed
greatness i've never don't even know
what it means to strive for that or try
to try to achieve anything
and yeah i think that's probably part of
what psychologically motivates it
uh tyler says matt you have bashed the
sanctity of miller light for that i'm
sad to say you're banned
i lift said band band when you read this
comment tomorrow
well you can't ban me because i ban you
and i i really don't
i honestly i i don't understand
every time i see someone drinking miller
light
okay if if these are college kids
and they're planning to dump these
things into a beer funnel or something
then okay i get that you're not gonna
use ipa for that you're not gonna use an
ipa for that application
it would be a waste of ipa but when i
see grown adults
who are just looking for a beer to sip
and have a nice time
miller lite was that literally the only
option you had
was it that or like a bottle of goat
urine were those the two options at your
liquor store
because even then i'm not so sure i'd
reach for the miller lite
and brent says controversial view maybe
but sweet baby gang isn't that great of
an inside joke wouldn't it be better to
have a shirt that says
all hail the theocratic dictator that
joke has been a much bigger part of the
show i'll suppose i'll be banned now
it's been fun
well you're obviously banned uh you know
it's okay if you don't like the sweet
baby gang
because you aren't invited anyway you're
not invited into it this gang is only
for true sweet babies
you sir are a sour baby i said it
and uh finally this is from nick
i read this comment yesterday and i was
honestly i was floored by it and
traumatized
nick says just an unfortunate fyi matt
the door closed button on elevators
only works on independent service or
fire service in normal service it won't
work
i happen to have the keys to make the
function work and can provide them for a
sweet baby gang shirt
well first of all that's a deal i'll
make but you're saying the door close
button on an elevator doesn't work
i read this comment yesterday and i
didn't believe it
are you telling me that the door closed
button is what a placebo
my whole life i hit the door close
button every single time
i rely on it i get this this is the
sense of security from it
and even satisfaction knowing that i'm
hitting the door close button while
there's someone walking down the hallway
and now they're going to have to wait i
get i get a sick cruel satisfaction
you're telling me that it doesn't do
anything so i had to look this up
and apparently that's true we have all
been lied to we've all been duped
with rare exception ever since 1990 i
discovered
uh because of the americans with
disability act um the door closed
buttons were all disabled
almost everywhere except except for like
in new york i think
so in new york you can still hit that
and cut anybody off even disabled people
they'll let new yorkers do that not
surprisingly but nobody else can
because you want the idea was we need to
get people more if someone's disabled
they have to have more time
to get on the elevator which doesn't
even make any sense because it's not
like
yeah even if if they're a bunch of
people
standing right at the elevator i'm not
going to run in and hit the door close
button to try to cut them all off even i
wouldn't do that
if they're walking down the hallway then
yeah i'll do that
but i would do that to anyone that's
just a disabled person
it's not because you're able-bodied or
disabled it's just because you're a
person and i'd rather not share this
space with you
it's all lights just like the crosswalk
button
you know there are some truths i got to
say this to you nick there are some
there are some truths that
that i think the world is not prepared
for
um and and this is one i think you
should have kept that to yourself
because i don't know what to do now with
my life now that i realize it's all been
a lie
how dare you i blame you for this you're
banned from the show
well if you have not had a chance to
catch uh candace owens's new show yet i
don't know what you're doing with your
life i don't know how many times we have
to tell you about it before you finally
give it a shot but if you haven't this
is the perfect episode to uh
to watch is there's a perfect
introduction i think into canis owens
and the candace show
um in the latest episode she discusses
the protests in cuba and weighs in on
marxism with mma fighter beneale darius
great interview you don't want to miss
that miss that so watch candace
you can go to daily wire right now to
watch candace you can also of course
download the audio podcast
and uh remember if you if you like what
you hear to leave that five star review
on apple spotify or whatever your
platform of choice may be also
i gotta let you know um if you've if you
haven't seen the disturbing clip of a
man dressed as an over sexualized animal
reading to children
then well you probably saw that clip
because i played it but
if you didn't i wouldn't recommend it
instead i'd suggest reading up on the
connection between the ideological
indoctrination of children and
authoritarianism so you can learn how to
spot this and stop
it before it's too late it's not it's
not hard to spot when it's a guy dressed
in a rainbow monkey
as a rainbow monkey with his genitalia
on display but how do you stop it
that's an important question and
currently your best course of action for
learning that is pre-ordering
ben shapiro's new book the authoritarian
moment don't wait
arm yourself with the knowledge you need
to shut america's tyrants down in their
tracks before it's too late the
authoritarian moment
is available now for pre-order at amazon
barnes noble or any other
major bookseller now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we must
revisit the body positivity movement or
the fat acceptance movement or the fat
liberation movement there are many
different
names for this movement all sorts of
movements are associated with the
celebration of fatness which is ironic
seeing as how
a lack of movement is exactly what leads
to fatness in the first place but
we begin with the trials and
tribulations of fat people when they are
traveling
a viral tick-tock video featuring a
teacher by the name of mary frances
donnelly purports to show the sort of
discrimination that obese individuals
encounter simply by checking into a
hotel room
this is apparently a whole series of
videos but we'll watch just one
to get the idea here it is welcome to
our hotel's fat phobic
with me your host your president
come hither let's take a look at the
battleground
as one might see it looks normal would
you like to take a pee or a poop
don't worry you'll barely fit
go outside
[Music]
so she appears to have a good sense of
humor about things in that video which
is nice
uh a nice change of pace from the the
sort of hectoring
scold tone that you get for most tick
tock videos of this sort but a report
from abc news explains that this is no
laughing matter
they interviewed donnelly about her
traveling as a fat person series and
this is how she explained it quote this
video was my way of highlighting a very
real stress i felt for years and have
only recently begun to unpack as i have
looked at my existence as a fat slash
plus-sized person in this world the
article then continues
while the tone of the videos is light
these things can affect how travelers
move within that space
donnelly isn't alone the comment section
on our video are flooded with people
in solidarity offering up similar
experiences quote i travel with my own
bath sheet and pool towel to avoid the
tiny towel debacle shown in the tik-tok
video
annette richman founder of fat girls
traveling told gma
quote i have to become a travel
detective while booking accommodations
investigating the hotel chairs and bed
frames
avoiding plastic chairs chairs with arms
and metal bed frames at all costs
because they can buckle under pressure
um the message this sends the plus side
travelers donnelly said is that a
vacation can't truly be a vacation
travelers either have to deal with
humiliation or prime a trip with hours
of research into what a room's sizing
and amenities may look like she said
quote
simple things like a towel size or
whether a chair is stable enough to hold
a person's weight is completely
disregarded
and chalked up to the traveler's issue
she said quote it furthers the narrative
that larger bodied people are expected
to roll with the punches and
accept this sort of treatment because
since the dawn of diet culture
we've made we've been made to feel like
we're the problem
okay well i'm not sure if there's any
delicate way to put this but if you find
that you need to research ahead of time
what sort of furniture will be in your
hotel room for fear that it won't
support your weight then yes
ma'am you are the problem or rather
we should say you have the problem the
problem is that you
carry so much weight on your body that
an average piece of furniture cannot
sustain it
whose problem is that if not yours i
mean who has introduced
that problem into the equation who's
really at fault
apparently the hotel is at fault for not
making their chairs out of i don't know
concrete
we can find a similar theme in another
article published this week
this one from the website fast company
about the changes your workplace should
make in order to better accommodate the
fattest among us
it gives a number of helpful tips like
suggesting that any office wellness
programs should be quote weight neutral
in other words you should redefine
wellness to include morbid obesity and
heart disease
in other words you should redefine
wellness to include unwellness
of course we're warned that any office
swag like t-shirt should come in large
enough sizes that it could
potentially double as a bed sheet and
then it says this about the furniture
quote companies that are serious about
size inclusion should look at their
facilities and workspaces
says peggy howell vice chairman and
public relations director of the
national association
to advance fat acceptance think about
including seats without arms or a
combination of typical chairs and bench
seating
to accommodate larger bodies the
organization has a
has created an hr guide and defines a
size friendly chair
as one with a seat size of 22.2
25 inches and a back size of 23 inches
width
and 23 inches height chair seats should
be height adjustable and should
accommodate at least
450 pounds
at least 450 pounds think about that
just for reference andre the giant was
only 70 pounds heavier than that at 520
pounds but he was well over seven feet
tall
aaron gibson was an offensive lineman
and one of the heaviest men to ever play
in the nfl
he was six foot six and clocked in at
around 410 pounds
most nfl linemen weigh 300 pounds less
than that so to be clear
the national association for fatigue
says that in order to be truly fat
accepting
you must specifically accommodate people
who are who are heavier
than the heaviest nfl player to ever
play the game
and i don't mean to belabor the point
here okay but
the tallest man in recorded history was
a guy named robert wadlow
he was almost nine feet tall he reached
i think was 811 is what he is what he
reached by the time of his death
nine feet tall and he weighed 440 pounds
okay the people who weigh 440 pounds
today are not nine feet tall many of
them aren't even six feet tall
so my point here is just that 450 pounds
is very very very overweight
i think in order by the cdc's bmi
calculation
in order for 450 to be to be a normal or
healthy weight
you would have to be like nine and a
half feet tall
so when the when the fat acceptance
movement
calls for fat acceptance they aren't
simply saying that we should get rid of
the beauty standards which demand that
women
all have the weight and physique of an
upside down mop you know most of us
agree
that rail thin should not be the
standard and it isn't the standard
anymore
and hasn't been for a while i mean
everyone agrees on that
but fat acceptance goes way beyond that
they're calling for acceptance of
extreme
morbid dangerous fatal obesity
the type that requires a lifestyle of
chronic gluttony and laziness to achieve
yeah there are there are thyroid
conditions there are you know people
have different
body types and all of that people have
different metabolisms i get all of that
but that doesn't explain 450 pounds that
doesn't explain
morbid obesity
and for that reason fat acceptance is an
evil despicable
anti-human movement it's not different
it's no different from anorexia
acceptance
or bulimia acceptance it's just on the
opposite end of the spectrum
there is no difference morally speaking
it is a celebration of self-destruction
either way
and there's something else too i mean
this fat acceptance stuff is a symptom
of a larger problem
pun sort of intended the problem is that
in our culture today
we're losing one of the most basic
skills or the most fundamental
capacities for any living organism
that is the ability to adapt to our
surroundings
okay now now like any capacity this has
to be moderated
it's possible to be too adaptive to try
and blend in too much but when properly
utilized
adaptation for a human being means
simply that we are conforming ourselves
and our behavior to the structures of
reality
we are accommodating reality and like we
talked about in the opening these days
though
accommodation is supposed to go the
other way around we constantly expect
that reality
will accommodate us so we're going to be
however we want to be
and whoever we want to be and we demand
that all of reality all of society
fit in around us we walk through our
lives every day like moses standing in
front of the red sea
demanding that it part and allow us to
walk across only whereas moses
used the power of the almighty to part
to see we try to use the power of
social pressure pressure of cancel
culture of activism of government
or some combination of these to
accomplish the same end
and it works oftentimes the entitled
whiny baby who's able to brow beat
everyone else into conforming themselves
to him
he's able to do that so that he doesn't
have to conform himself to them
they accommodate him instead of him
accommodating them
does often work these days
it works in that immediate sense anyway
but it doesn't work in the deeper sense
it doesn't make the whiny baby happy or
fulfilled
that's why he remains a whiny baby even
after he gets what he wants
he is still miserable because he's
clinging on to his own destruction
the thing that he refuses to let go of
is the very thing
that is causing his despair
the thing that he wants everyone to
accommodate accommodate
is the thing that's destroying him he
can force everyone to pretend that these
bad parts of himself are good
but he can't actually make the bad parts
good they're still bad
they'll still destroy him they will
still make him unhappy
because in the end reality wins it
always does
one way or another even after all of us
are gone
reality remains and for that reason
the woman in that tic-tock video is
cancelled
once again it was a long journey to get
there but we get back around to the
cancellation
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
my sweet babies
talk to you tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical directors austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright
dailywire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show president
biden goes fully radical by declaring
half the country akin to jim crow racist
texas democrats fly private and live it
up in dc while declaring they are
fighting for the people and
the biden state department says we must
answer for our racism to the united
nations that's today on the bench bureau
shall give it a listen